one woman at my sentence i won't say the
names
she told my judge
when i was first getting sentenced
give him life
zakila is this he's that he's a serial
killer he's this and that
so the judge looked at her and read her
statement
and the judge says
your brother
who you're talking for was in his crew
did it ever bother you
he was killing people with him
it only bothered you when he got killed
it never bonded you before
killing other people
he just shut her [ __ ] right the [ __ ]
down with that statement really
and it was truthful
and they just disregarded what she was
saying
because it was all [ __ ] so that's
what you deal with you're dealing with
all this hypothetical [ __ ]
you know you're protecting him he was a
saint anybody who died there was saint
you know after they died but before they
died they were involved in five murders
or whatever
how did when did he become the saint
after he died
so
so in your mind is
anybody that was in that life they were
fair game it's they got what they signed
up for anybody you know the real problem
is if somebody had done something like
demayo did things to people outside of
life that that's that's crossing the
line
two things i'll get to the mail in a
minute but the thing is
this is gonna sound strange but
i'm a samurai warrior
in japan they samurais
they fight they're very dangerous they
cut off arms heads legs when they lose
battles they take a [ __ ] thing and
stab it and they there is a culture in
japan
they're samurais they're warriors
they're loved over there and respected
but they don't do this outside of their
thing
so when i'm talking to somebody now the
guy called me assembler
warrior
he said you have the mafia is a culture
within this country
that did a lot of
good things a lot of [ __ ] up things
so
but we did it within our culture
so we're warriors maybe not i'm not a
japanese and i'm not a samurai but
similar
if you want to break it down and every
country has that
culture
so we're different uh which will lead me
right into roy demayo
roy del mayo became a serial killer
i mean
i'm about to do a video about him and
his crew
one time i went to him and
paul was going to make guys
and i knew him and i said
they're going to open the books again
and they're going to make guys you got
some good guys around you you're going
to put anybody up for it
he said sam
my coffee boy killed five people with me
what
your coffee boy killed five people yeah
he says i got 200 hits
200.
i said what the [ __ ] is giving you this
kind of work
he said nobody
i get a lot of work from the boss and
this and that
from nino
but
we have the bar on the corner
he said
my uncle works there they used to call
him dracula
he says he calls me up at 4 30 3 30.
we're playing cards tells me there's a
guy left one guy drunk
we come in we snatch them we bring them
in we kill them cut them up get rid of
them
the guy did nothing
no
i keep my crew
tight
sharp you know what i mean
i didn't want to answer that i said yeah
yeah i do the same thing yeah
but in my head i was saying this is a
sick
[ __ ] guy he crossed that line he's a
[ __ ] cereal because killing [ __ ]
innocent people
and this is why the mafia killed him
we are we're not serial killers
if we become a rapist
a child molester
or a serial killer we will kill you
within our ranks we will kill you we're
not proud of you we don't like you
we will kill you
we killed for different reasons you
broke rules or you did certain things
but those things you got killed for sure
we don't give [ __ ] who you are
[Music]
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you